Over the last 20 or 25 videos, we have
learned a lot of concepts. And in all of
that, we have never written a test. That
was intentional. And we'll see why in
this video. Because writing a bad test,
writing a test in hurry, writing an
incomplete test is more harmful than not
having tests at all. Because they give
you a false sense of confidence about
your code, about your application.
And that is why I did not want to keep a
small part in testing for each one of
those videos where the concepts
themselves were of importance and not
the test. So in this video we are going
to cover everything there is about
testing and we'll justify it as much as
we can. So let's define what exactly do
we mean by a test. A test is a second
program that runs your program and it
makes claims about what all things
happened. And there are a lot of reasons
to write tests. We have this whole area
this whole style of development called
test-driven development where you write
the tests first and then write the code
so that you have your goal in mind what
you want to achieve with your program.
So there are different different
motivations of writing test either as a
guidance or documentation but primarily
the most useful reason the most
important reason for writing tests is to
catch regressions. What do I mean by
regressions? Regression basically means
that you wrote some code, you wrote some
logic in your codebase a few months back
and as you keep adding more and more
features to your codebase, you want to
ensure that the previous features still
function exactly as they used to when
you first time tested them manually or
first time use them. And every single
thing that we are going to cover in this
video, every type of test, every metric,
every tool that is just a variation of
this definition that uh we just saw and
testing itself is a huge field. Uh there
are people whose whole job is about
testing. There are job titles dedicated
to testing and different kinds of
testing. So to scope it a little bit of
what we mean in this video about what
kind of testing we are going to cover
what a backend engineer writes and runs
themselves which is about 80% of the
testing that happens in a normal team.
We are not going to cover the corporate
style manual QA process and other tools
that are available like test management
tools, mobile testing or browser
automation for front ends and all these
areas of testing. The application that
we are going to test in this video is
the same task board that we saw in the
last video. So let's see the code before
we write any tests on top of it. So this
is our codebase. It has around 11 Go
files and that is pretty much the whole
server. The cmd/board is the binary, the
executable binary and main is the only
place that knows how to put everything
together. Internal/board is the domain
for different different features like
tasks, columns etc. Internal/hub
this holds uh the rooms since we are
talking about boards and task
management. And every subscriber in a
room has its own counter. Then we have
internal/bus.
This is an interface with two methods
and it has two different kinds of
implementations. First one keeps
everything in process. That is the one
that we are going to use for testing and
that is one of the uh core use cases of
interfaces so that you can have the same
same API same interface but two
different implementations behind it. The
second one the real one is going to use
radius for our actual application. Then
we have internal store. This also has
the similar structure. We have an
interface with three methods and there
is posgress behind them. And we also
have internal HTTP API. This holds the
whole route table so that you can look
at one file and know what all API
endpoints that we are exposing all the
URLs. And one thing uh to notice here is
there are no tests in this codebase yet.
That's what we are going to write. And
for those who do not have any
familiarity with the Go programming
language, that is fine. One of the
claims of this playlist is you do not
need to know any specific programming
language to watch these videos. As long
as you are a programmer and you code in
any other language, that is fine. We are
using a particular language in this so
that you have a concrete understanding
of what exactly the code does. We will
of course keep most part of this video
as theoretical as conceptual instead of
focusing too much on code. But there has
to be a few parts which needs to show
some code so that you can map the same
understanding to a different programming
language instead of just having a
theoretical understanding because tests
in theory is not a lot. It's it's not
very complex right the code the thinking
tests in code that is the core part of
it. So let's start by understanding
tests. First thing that I have already
mentioned a test is a program. It is a
different program than your existing
application or your back end. But it is
a program in itself. So a test is a
piece or a snippet of code that calls
your existing code and it looks at what
it gives some kind of inputs which we
decide beforehand and it looks at the
output and if it does not match what we
were expecting then it complains it
throws errors it it crashes it panics
whatever terminology that you are
familiar with in a very primary sense
even Even if you don't have any kind of
testing tools, any testing libraries or
frameworks or the whole technicalities
of the whole test ecosystem in a very
fundamental sense if you wrote a
normallooking program and does not
matter whatever programming language
let's say the same programming language
that you uh wrote your back end in and
you just checked two things you called
some part of your actual back end
through a different function. Let's call
this function your test and you just
wrote an if condition that if output is
not equals to 20 or something then you
throw error or you return error or you
throw exception whatever you're familiar
with right that is a test even without
going into all the complexities of
testing ecosystem but over the time
people have realized that that is not
enough considering how complex our back
end has become, how complex our
applications has become in real world.
Handwriting your conditions, handwriting
your test runners, handwriting your
mocking, all these different concepts
every time you want to test your program
that is not very scalable and that is
the logic behind any other library. Why
do people write libraries in the first
place? so that they solve the problem
once and they let everyone else solve
their problems using the same library
instead of reinventing the wheel every
time. Okay. So what a programming
language gives you if you're using a
programming language like Go then it
comes with its own testing um module its
own testing features and every
programming language has uh some kind of
inbuilt testing mechanism but we use
libraries and frameworks on top of that
to make our experience more developer
friendly and more uh intuitive. So what
a programming language or a framework
gives you for testing is a test runner.
What is a testr runner? It is a program
that finds all your test files. So I am
talking in in the context of go
programming language. So in a go testr
runner, it finds all your test files
across the whole codebase and it runs
them and in the end it gives you a very
uh beautiful looking report of how many
tests passed and how many of them
failed. So this is the first test in
this codebase. What it does, it creates
a board and it moves a task from one
column to another and it checks that the
task ended up where we expected it to
end up or where we asked it to end up.
And here I have made a mistake on
purpose so that we can watch it fail.
And this is what it gives us the test
binary. It prints the file the line
number and what it wanted versus what it
got. Uh the task it got was in doing and
the test wanted it done. Now we fix the
expectation and let's run it again and
it passes instantly. Now let's look at
what is happening behind it. I run it
with dash work which tells the tool to
keep the folder it builds in instead of
deleting it after it runs and it prints
me the path. And if you look inside it
there is a file in there called
underscore test main.go and we did not
write it. the tool wrote it. And if you
read it, it says package main and it has
a list called tests with every test
function it found in our package. And at
the bottom, it has a funk main which is
the main executable for this testing
program which calls testing.main start
and then the os.exit for exiting the
program. Now we run it once more with
dash x and what that does is it prints
every command that the tool runs and it
reads the last few lines. So it links a
binary called board.est and then it runs
board.est.
So go test writes a main function,
compiles it into a program and executes
the program. So far what we learned a
test is a program and what is a runner?
a runner, no matter what programming
language, it writes the main function,
the main executable where the uh
execution starts for any kind of binary
for you instead of you having to write
it and then it collects all the results.
That's pretty much the whole idea behind
using all these frameworks and test
runners. Okay, moving on to the next
concept which is the part inside your
test that actually does the complaining.
That is what we call as an assertion. An
assertion is a check that either stops
or fails the whole test when the
condition is not true. In most languages
to use all these assertions, we use a
library and the libraries they give you
uh these very useful functions and
sentences like assert equals, assert not
equals, assert number and all this
stuff. And but in a programming language
like Go there is no separate assert
function in the standard library you
just write an if statement and when the
condition is wrong you just call t dot
error f and you just write the message
yourself and uh the language works it
out. One thing to remember here when you
are writing tests is in all your
assertions in a language like Go you
directly write the message. So it works
out without you thinking a lot. But in
other programming languages always make
sure that you are writing a very
meaningful failure message so that
whoever is looking at the failing test
they know exactly what to check what
exactly failed and enough information so
that they can debug the whole thing. I
have already mentioned this but
regression [clears throat]
is something that you will hear a lot
when we are talking about tests and
regression is basically a bug that you
had already fixed in your past but it
comes again it comes back that's what we
mean by regression so uh it it can
happen because somebody in your team
they changed a function or they changed
an interface or they changed a
particular a logical behavior and
something happened, right? Which is very
normal when you are working in a team.
But the best part about writing tests is
you catch the regressions instantly
because typically what we have is in our
CI system in our continuous integration
system which is what we mean when we say
if you're using something like GitHub
actions or something there usually we
have a CI workflow for running our
tests. So every time we raise a new PR
before that PR is merged into your main
branch or develop branch that whole test
suite runs and if any of the tests fail
then we know instantly that this new
piece of code that we are trying to
merge it is causing regressions. It is
going to cause bugs that we have already
fixed and because of that you can
instantly fix it instead of finding out
from your users complaining about a
feature failing. And that behavior is
the most useful thing about a test suite
which is you can move rapidly. You can
add features very quickly without
worrying about your existing features
breaking because you already have a very
deterministic test suite which tests
every single condition, every single
bugs that had happened in the past. So
you are enforcing that with the new
piece of code those bugs are still
staying fixed instead of coming back. So
now that we know what a single test is,
let's explore what are the different
kinds of tests that are available to us.
Starting with unit test. What do we call
as unit test? A unit test is a test of
one unit of your code in isolation. It
does not care about the surrounding code
where it runs. Now the question is what
can we consider as a unit? Is it a
function or is it a strct or is it just
a package or it is a whole service? How
do you know what can we consider as a
unit? And the answer to that is there is
no universal definition for that. There
is no universal answer. It is just
something that you have to learn to
recognize over time when you write more
and more tests. So if you take a
function that does something some kind
of execution and that function calls two
or three other things to do its job. In
that case you have two choices. You can
either while testing this main function
which calls other functions, you can
either let the function call the actual
other functions or you can hand in mocks
while running or testing this function.
And in both the cases, both of them can
be considered as unit tests. So let's
see what that looks like in the task
board that we just saw. Here there is a
same behavior and we are testing it in
four different ways. In the first one,
the we give the board a mock bus instead
of the real bus logic which is just a
small object which records what it was
asked to publish and that's it. It does
nothing else. It does not actually
perform any kind of bus logic. We'll get
to what are the different kinds of mocks
or standins that are available to us.
The second one here it uses the real
bus, the actual bus and the actual hub.
So when we do a move in the board, this
actually goes to a subscriber. Now the
third one, it starts an actual HTTP
server on an actual port and it sends a
real post request and it also reads the
actual response. Now if you look at the
numbers, all are 0 0. And if you look at
the fourth one, we are running the same
check but this time against a real
posgress database which takes 10 and a
half seconds. And most of it is because
the container the posgress container is
booting up. So the the thing that I want
to point out here is the most expensive
time-taking part of a test is not how
much of logic that you are trying to
cover because we just saw that one of
the tests went through the actual entire
HTTP stack and for that also we got
zero. But the one that actually cost us
some latency was the Postgress one. Why?
Because it left our existing process.
Right? That is the point to remember.
It's not how much you are covering in a
unit test or a test. It is about whether
you are leaving your existing process
and going into an external territory or
not. Okay. Now let's cover two more.
Integration test. An integration test is
a test that checks two or more parts
that are working together. And most of
the cases when we write an integration
test, the first part is of course our
application, our back end, our logic.
But the other part or parts, they are
usually external, which means uh
something that we did not write
something like a database. And then an
end to- end test that is a test that
goes through the whole system in the
same way that an actual user will go an
actual user of our platform all the
activities an actual user will do. This
test will have all those properties.
What does that mean? uh the integration
test and the end to end test they both
sound similar but the difference is an
end toend test will have to cover every
single path which means that what is the
first thing that a user need to do to
start using our platform which is
authentication. So the first part of
your end to end test will have to
include authentication and then it will
take that token that session whatever it
recorded for an actual user login it
will use the same session then to test
other parts let's say the user navigates
to the dashboard page then it calls this
API then it creates a task all these
things so it will try to map it will try
to follow a user through their journey
into the platform that is the end to end
test but in integration testing
We will be using our internal logic so
that we don't actually have to do a
login. We can just create a task with
because the authentication middleware is
something that we have enforced for our
users. We can of course bypass it. So
integration testing does not have to
respect every single path a user will
take in our platform. Now if you have
read anything about testing or you have
read any articles then you must have
seen this famous test pyramid where the
wide base that is for the unit tests
then comes a few integration tests and
then on the top a cap for the end to end
tests and what that picture actually
means is it is saying that the bottom
ones the base ones which has a longer
width they are extremely cheap and they
extremely fast. The ones on top, they
keep getting more and more expensive and
more and more slow. And when we say
expensive, it does not always have to
mean money or paying a bill. It can be
expensive in the sense of uh spending
your CPU resources, spending your
memory, spending your time. So this
whole pyramid thing, it is about cost.
The higher you go on the pyramid, the
more expensive and slow your tests are.
And the pyramid has been a very good
resource for a lot of years when people
talk about tests and how much to test
and which parts of test and a lot of
arguments around testing itself. There
are a lot of resources you'll find on
the pyramid concept. But instead of
going the theoretical way of thinking
about test, I want to discuss a more
practical way something that I use. So
instead of asking how much of the system
a particular test covers, you should ask
how much a test is allowed to touch in
your system. Okay? And I'll I'll explain
what that means. A small test, it runs
in one process. It does not touch your
network. It does not touch your
database. And you do not have to do any
artificial sleeping. And it also does
not touch your file system. a medium
level test that may talk to a few things
that is on the same machine. A database
that is running in your local container
or a radius instance that is in another
container in your local only. Similarly,
everything is in the same machine but it
still cannot reach the internet. It does
not go outside the machine. But a large
test, the final upper level test that
can do anything. Okay, that's that's a
better mental model to think about tests
in my opinion. And the reason is nobody
can claim nobody can check whether a
test is actually a unit test or not.
Why? Because there is no universal
definition of a unit test and nobody
agrees with anyone when it comes to
discussions about testing. Everyone has
their own opinions of what exactly is a
unit test. But the machine the the
machine where you are doing the
development and testing itself that can
check whether your test actually opened
a socket or not. Because of that it
becomes a rule which you can enforce
instead of a vague argument or a vague
opinion. There is a famous highly
discussed term that we use whenever we
are talking about testing is a flaky
test. What a flaky test means is
sometimes the test passes, sometimes the
test fails. It is not deterministic and
it depends on the environment that it is
running. But if you think about tests in
this model, in the model where we are
thinking inside the machine, inside the
process or outside the machine, then the
whole flakiness of any test that can
completely eliminate it. Why? Because if
it is inside the machine then we can
push the determinism of the test to its
peak because it does not talk to the
internet itself. That's where most of
the flakiness lies because there are
external services that servers have
their own clocks and all these
complexities. So the first three unit
test, integration test and end to- end
test they answer the question that how
much of the system does this test
actually touch. So this whole thing is
about scope. Then we have different
varieties of them to answer different
different other questions. For example,
we have regression testing. Those are
the tests that we use to catch the bugs
to catch the errors that have already
happened and we don't want them to
happen again. Okay, they are
specifically for catching a particular
list of bugs. Then functional testing
that is what uh I mentioned in the first
of the video when I say test-driven
development where you write the
specification of the application
specification of your feature first and
based on that specification which is the
test itself then you write your
application or your pro your program and
because of that after you're done with
your application or your feature or your
logic you already have a readym made uh
test or readymade verification layer
which will tell you whether you are done
or not. Okay, that's what we mean by
functional testing. Then we have
performance testing which mostly tests
how fast your program is and not just
the speed, it also tests how much memory
that you are consuming, how much CPU
that you are consuming and all those uh
separate things which is concerned about
performance. Then there is security
testing which is to expose whether your
program tries to bypass any security
layer like any secure container layer or
your file systems or uh the cookies or
something which is related to privacy or
security. That's what you are trying to
find with security testing whether your
program is secure or not. Whether it
respects privacy or not. Okay. So those
are a variation of different tests for
different different scenarios but they
are not a different kind of test than a
unit or integration or end to end test.
They are just different variations. So
technically a regression test can be a
unit test and similarly uh a security
test which checks whether you are
breaching any kind of privacy or not
that can be an end toend test also.
Similarly uh functional testing and
integration testing they sound or seem
similar because functional testing is
just a variation of integration testing.
So all these different kinds of testing
that we uh have a list for they are just
all variations of these three different
kinds of test unit integration and end
to end which we have already scoped to
our mental model which is about the
scope either it is in process or in
machine or it touches internet or not
okay that's pretty much all the
terminologies that you need to know to
move ahead okay I just wanted to cover
these terminologies ies because this is
what most people still use in the
industry and you need to know what those
things mean but personally I don't
really think in terms of unit
integration or end to end in my mental
model it is only about the things that
the tests are touching the things that
they are uh interacting with okay the
mental model is the scope okay and that
is how we are going to uh approach
everything for the rest of the you. Now,
we'll see why most people don't write
tests in the first place. Look at the
task board. When somebody moves a task,
the handler asks the board to apply that
change and then it publishes an event on
the event bus. So, every other connected
browser finds out about that particular
task moving. We covered this in the uh
previous video in the realtime systems
how events propagate from the client to
the server through the event bus to all
the other clients. So in a real back end
that particular handler it also has to
write to the database posgress and then
it might also have to call a payment
provider um to check their credits or
something like that and then it might
also have to send an email which is
again an external service. So now the
question is how do you test a
functionality of a particular workflow
when you have to interact with your
database interact with your payment
provider and uh send a actual email to
your users and all these external things
that you need to do all these external
connections that you have to establish.
How do you test that? And the answer to
that is you give that particular
function something which looks and acts
like the external service would. And
that mock that standin that is what we
call as a test double. And the name test
double it comes from movies and films
because they use stunt doubles in
movies. So that the the stunt man the
stun double they can perform risky
action stunts in place of the actual
actor but when we watch the movie for us
it looks like the actor is performing
the stunts. Now the test double is a is
a name of the category. There are five
different types here for the test double
and they do different kinds of things.
Five different things and pretty much
all of us call all those five different
things a mock because that's the most
intuitive word for everything related to
testables. The first one is called a
dummy. What is a dummy? A dummy is a
value that you pass into a function
because the function's signature asks
for it but it is never actually used.
For example, let's say your your
constructor for your service in your
back end. It needs a logger which comes
from your main file from your main
function or somewhere. But in this case
while testing you do not really need
logging. We do not really care about
logging. So what you do you just hand a
dummy function or a function which does
nothing just returns or prints or
something that like that it does not
really have all the logging related
features and you just pass it in the
constructor and you say that okay this
is your logger now let's move on to the
next thing that is what we mean as a
dummy the second one is called a stub
what does a stub do basically gives you
the same response does not matter how
many times you ask and what you task.
For example, let's say you asked for
user ID 7 and it gives you back an
object which has the users details which
resembles whatever uh your database has
stored similar kinds of fields, right?
And we use stubs so that if we have a
dependency then it passes instead of
blocking on getting an actual user.
Okay, the stub basically means getting a
pre-written answer every time. does not
matter how many times you ask and what
we ask. The third is called a spy which
is the same as a stub. It also answers
the same thing every time. But on top of
that, it also records what all changes
that you made to it. So let's say you
ask for user ID 7, it gives you user ID
7. But if you say change the user's name
from X to Y, then it will also record
that you tried to change the name from X
to Y. Fourth is called a mock. A mock
usually has some conditions pre-written
for it. It has a few expectations set
beforehand. For example, if you have
already configured beforehand for the
mock that a particular save it should be
called exactly once with this argument
and during the testing if that does not
happen then it complains or it fails or
it errors. That's what we mean by mock.
And the fifth one is a fake. A fake is
um basically an implementation which is
not suited for production. It only
exists for testing and it it matches the
behavior. It matches the inputs and
outputs of the actual thing the actual
implementation. For example, let's say
you are trying to test your service and
in particular a method in the service
which creates a user. So in that place
if you're testing something which
depends on this service method what you
do you pass a fake for that service
method which instead of saving the user
in your actual postgrid database what it
will do it will create a map or a set or
whatever data storage in memory in the
program and it will save the user there.
So from the perspective of the function
that is actually calling the fake the
user still got saved it can still ask
for the user back but that is not the
actual database it was something else a
test implementation a dummy
implementation. So let's take one test
of the move handler and there are two
ways to write the check at the end. The
first way is to ask the board what state
it is right now which is like asking is
the task already in the done column or
did the sequence number go up by one. So
that is called state verification. The
second way to do the check is ask the
double what exactly did it see? Was the
publish function called once with an
event whose type is task. That is called
interaction verification and also
sometimes called as behavior
verification. Now here now if the code
changes but the behavior does not. For
example, if somebody decides that the
handler should publish one combined
event instead of two from the outside
nothing really changed. Every browser
still sees the same board. If we look at
the state verification that does not
really notice this change because the
state the end state is still the same
but here the interaction test the
behavior verification that fails you.
Why? Because the number of calls changed
instead of two events instead of two
event publish now it is one and then and
that is why it starts failing. And this
kind of thing has and this also has a
name which is called as change detector
test. So instead of testing the final
state or the result it checks the actual
behavior of the program the step-by-step
behavior not the end state of what it
achieved and Google has a very
interesting write up on this which you
can take a look. So this is the thumb
rule for this section. only assert only
check what the system is right now not
how it went there or how it was achieved
only do interaction verification or
change detection when that is absolutely
necessary which most of the times it is
not some of the use cases that you can
um have for an actual use for
interaction testing is let's say you are
sending emails to your users and you
want to make sure that the email went
exactly once
So there interaction testing can be very
useful but in most cases you should
depend on the state instead of the
behavior or interaction. That is one
mistake. The second mistake is let's say
your service calls a payment provider
and for obvious reasons you do not want
to charge a real card when you're trying
to test multiple times in a day. So what
you do you write a mock for their client
and you write it in a way that when
charge method is called with these
arguments it returns a success object
with these fields something like data
success message new balance. After that
your test passes and you deploy but the
whole thing fails in your production.
Why? Because everything that came out of
the test was what you already wrote,
what you had already configured.
Everything the the structure of the
success object, the field names, what
happens on a duplicate charge, which
errors they return and in which format,
all of them were configured by you. So
the rule to prevent that kind of mistake
is do not mock what you do not own. So
what you should do instead two things.
First you wrap the whole third party in
a small interface in a small wrapper
function or wrapper structure whatever
it is in your programming language which
has your own applications structures
your own success objects failure object
error messages everything of your own.
And then you use that wrapper in your
main workflow in your production and
also during testing. And now that you
own the interface, you are allowed to
test it. That is the first thing you
should do. Second thing is since you
cannot really uh test the whole charging
workflow which you can test once
manually but after that testing it every
time is not feasible. So what you do
most of these payment providers they
have their sandbox APIs right. So you
write a few small tests and what are
those tests for? They are to test your
interface whether the request structure,
the response structure, the success
structure, the failure structure,
everything that you're taking that
you're wrapping with your own interface
that matches with the actual product or
not, the actual platform or not. And
those tests can be very fast. They do
not uh deal with any kind of payment
data or anything. So that is something
that is more practical and feasible.
Okay. Now let's look at the handler. The
reason it was hard to test in the first
place was that it reached out and it
made its own dependencies out of thin
air. It created the database client
itself. It created the redisk client
itself, established the connection
itself. So when a function creates its
own dependencies, it creates the thing
that it depends on. As a result, you
cannot really replace those external
dependencies from outside from your
calling function. So what you can do
instead of the function itself creating
the dependencies you pass those
dependencies and how do you pass it
through parameters through arguments and
that workflow that technique is what we
call as dependency injection.
And there are a lot of frameworks
surrounding dependency injection. But
pretty much all of them do the same
thing. But as your program grows, as
your back end grows, becomes more and
more complex, you might need all these
frameworks to to make the dependency
injection workflow more developer
friendly. So this is the mental model
that you should have. Always push all
your decisions and your calculations,
your business logic, all the core part
of it into different different
functions. All of them should be pure.
Pure in the sense they should take
values and they should return values.
Then keep all the talking to the outside
world to the external internet, external
APIs and providers, databases, all these
things into a very thin layer around
them. The middle part is what we call as
a functional core. And the layer around
it is called a shell, the imperative
shell. And once you structure it like
this, the core part, the functional code
in the middle, that is very easy to
test. Why? Because it has nothing to
mock. Everything is owned by us. So we
can test every part of it. And the thin
layer around it that is hard to test.
But now since it is a very thin logic
layer, there is very little to test in
the first place. So in this structure it
becomes very easy or you are more likely
to write tests if you structure your
program your applications this way.
Okay. Now that we have learned we can
replace actual external dependencies
with our own. We need to decide. We need
to uh learn when and what can we
actually replace with our own fakes with
our own implementations instead of using
the real one and when the replacing
decision is right and when it is wrong.
The first one, the most common one is
database. And the instinct most people
have here is since the database is slow,
what we will do, we will wrap the
Postgress layer, the database layer with
something that executes all the
operations inside memory using strrus,
using maps or whatever data structure.
And our tests will not have any external
dependencies nor have any external
latency because of the database layer
and all of them can be executed in a few
seconds. So in programming language like
NodeJS people often do in-memory
replacements for this. In Go people
write some fake repository layers for
this. If you do Java or something then
you have H2. But there is a problem in
that because when you replace that
database with something fake, something
in memory, what you gain in return is
speed, maintainability and utilization.
But what are the trade-offs? What you
give up in return is fidelity. Because
let's think about it, what kind of bugs,
what kind of issues that actually live
in our data layer? things like a wrong
column name or a missing index that
makes the query slow or a unique
constraint that we forgot to check for
or we forgot to add. A transaction that
does not really do what it is expected
to do. Something like a JSON operator
that exists in Postgress but it does not
exist in our fake implementation or the
vice versa situation. And in every
single one of those scenarios, the
issues, the bugs actually live in the
Postgress layer, in the database layer.
They do not live in your logic. And that
is the exact layer that you replaced
with your in-memory replacement. So what
is the solution to this? The answer is
to use a real database for your tests
and you make it cheap. you make it very
developer friendly so that you don't
have to reach out for in-memory
replacements and there are two
techniques to do that. First one is a
transaction per test. So what you do is
at the start of the test you open a
transaction you run everything inside it
and at the end you roll back instead of
doing the committing and now the
database is completely untouched and
when you start the next test it starts
as a clean slate. You never have to
worry about corrupting the data and this
is also very fast. But the only
requirement for this is the code that
you are running instead of taking a
database handle it should be able to
take a transaction handle otherwise this
is not going to work. But this is
something that we already discussed that
in the dependency injection layer that
your functions should be able to take
the dependencies instead of creating
them. Now the second one the second way
of testing with real database is using a
template database. If you are using
something like posgress it lets you
create a database as a copy of your
existing database. So you run all your
migrations on the template and every
test creates its own database from the
template in a few milliseconds which is
extremely fast. you will not really see
the latency and because of this the
tests can also run in parallel because
they each have their own database and to
actually use a real posgress instance
for your test there is a famous library
called test containers and it has the
language SDKs in pretty much all the
programming languages which makes it
extremely easy to do all these
operations using posgress database or
any other database they have different
different database port also. What it
does is it starts a real container from
uh your test code and it gives you back
the address the address of the container
where you can reach the actual database.
Let's see the demo of how what it
actually looks like. If you see the top
of that output test containers, it
starts a actual Postgress 18 version
instance and then it waits until it
accepts a connection. And if you look at
the two timestamps, the container starts
at 58 seconds past the minute and it is
ready at 5 seconds past the next one. So
in total that is 7 seconds and it
happens once for the whole package not
once per test. Now if you watch the nine
tests under it, each one makes its own
database by copying the template and
then it runs extremely fast almost a few
milliseconds.
So the whole package the total time to
test the whole package the container
latency and all of it is just 10 and a
half seconds out of which setting up the
real database that costs you around 7
seconds for the whole setup and then for
the next 3 seconds it runs all the tests
which executes the actual testing logic.
Okay, that is all about database. Now
let's talk about network which is when
your application or your code it calls
someone else's API it calls some
external API and as we learned uh in the
past section for this scenario always
wrap the external service or the
external layer with your own interface
your own API your own wrapper and then
in your test layer you try to mock that
or fake that but there is a second
technique here which is useful when you
actually want to test the HTTP call. You
want to test your own client code. You
also want to interact with your headers,
right? You want to set them. You want to
delete them. All those operations, you
want to be the one who calls the server
through the HTTP instead of just calling
the functions from inside. If you are
using Go, it gives you this library
called REST. But other languages in
NodeJS, Python, they also have their own
uh very famous maintained libraries for
doing the same thing. What it does, it
starts a actual HTTP server on an actual
port in your test and then you point
your client towards that. So when the
request happens, it actually goes
through TCP protocol like it does in
production. If you're using NodeJS,
there is a famous library called MSW. it
intercepts at the network layer instead
of you having to replace your client.
And with this setup, you can test your
own handlers from the other side. Now
the third thing which is time and this
one causes a lot of issues because let's
see a scenario. You call some function
and something happens in the background
and the test needs to wait for it
because it is async. So in that scenario
what we do we write some kind of sleep
function which is available in every
programming language and we sleep for
let's say 100 milliseconds and then we
try to check the result instead of
checking instantly. So sometimes it
passes on our laptops in our local
development environments and it also
passes during any kind of review then
when you push it to our CI continuous
integration environment through GitHub
action or something there it fails. Why?
because the thing that you're trying to
um fake which is waiting a few seconds
so that the background process can
finish in that machine since there is a
lot of load and the machine was busy
instead of taking 100 milliseconds it
took 110 milliseconds. So here the issue
was not because you were wrong in your
logic. The problem is about the clock is
about the time. And of course the
obvious fix and a naive fix is just
increasing the time. But that does not
really fix it permanently. If the server
is busier in some other day then you'll
again have to increase the time and then
your tests are again slower. So that is
not the right fix. There are two
different solutions for this. The first
one is to stop waiting for a duration
and instead wait for a condition which
means instead of waiting a abstract
amount of time you wait for some kind of
signal. So if you're using go you wait
for an event that comes from a channel.
If you are using NodeJS then you wait
for a particular call back. So now you
are not trying to guess the time but you
are waiting for the actual completion
event. And the second solution is you
pass the clock itself. A lot of
languages, a lot of libraries offer this
uh feature where you can pass an
instance of a clock which means instead
of checking actual time, it will depend
on the past implementation of the clock
of the time to check its logic and then
you have complete control over the times
and the timeouts. One last concept
before we move on to the next thing is
this whole idea that we discussed where
a test which brings its own surrounding
its own environment with it and that
does not depend on a database that
somebody set up by hand or a service
that has to be running. This environment
this kind of testing is called as
hermitic testing. Hermitic basically
means sealed, freeze, sealed or frozen.
Everything that a test needs, it starts
and once it is done, it stops everything
that it has started. And you need that
property if you want to run your tests
in any machine, whether it is your local
or an SSH server or your GitHub actions
environment anywhere. And this library
that we saw test containers it is a way
of being hermetic about a database and
the injected clock technique that we saw
that is being hermetic about time. So
that is another technical terminology
that you'll hear when talking about
testing. Okay. Now that we can write a
test that survives any kind of
refactoring that your team might do.
Let's talk about a practice which is I
have already mentioned called testdriven
development also known as TDD which is a
practice of writing the test writing the
specification before the code itself. It
is a way of working it is a workflow
instead of a kind of test because it
does not really do any special kind of
its own tests. It still has the typical
unit test, integration test and E2E
tests. It's just the workflow. It's just
the way of working. The only difference
is when you are writing them typically
instead of writing after our programming
logic, after our application or back end
logic, you write them beforehand. So the
whole loop of test event development has
three stages or three colors. Red is you
write a test for something that does not
exist yet and you run it and it should
fail. Okay, that is the first step. Then
is green. You write the smallest amount
of code that makes it pass. And here you
are expected or you are allowed to write
bad code or a code that does not adhere
to every single best practice. But the
only purpose is it should pass the test.
And then in the last stage is refactor.
Now that the test is passing, the test
is green. You do a little bit of clean
up, a little bit of restructuring. And
after that you run the test again. If it
is still passing, then you have your
clean code with the functionality
already tested. So here the first step
this phase is for the design because if
you are writing the test beforehand
before you write your application logic
it forces you to imagine your function
to use your function before it exists.
So the way you would imagine it as its
API how you are going to use it not how
it is going to work and doing that you
will find out what it should look like
from the outside from the calling
function instead of what it should look
like from implementation side and while
doing so you will realize it quickly if
the test is becoming hard to write or if
the test seems ugly or awkward awkward
then you will realize that the interface
the API that you're imagining your
function will have there is a problem
with it there is an issue with it so you
find out instantly in a few seconds or a
few minutes instead of realizing in the
end and then you have to restructure the
whole function expose new parameters and
all so that is one advantage of writing
the test beforehand which you do in the
first step in the first stage of
testdriven development then the second
step which is for the proof
Because if you imagine it the other way
around, let's say you write some code
and then as per the code's workings, you
write a test and since you wrote the
code yourself, you already know the
logic and the thing that you're testing,
the logic that you're testing is most
probably going to pass on your first
attempt. Why? You're the one who wrote
the application. You do not really learn
anything. There is no way to find out
whether the test actually passed because
the code is right or it passed because
it does not really check what it is
supposed to check. So first making it
red and then turning it green has a
learning experience which comes with
testdriven development which does not
come when you write the application code
first. Kent Beck, he has a whole list of
these properties that he expects from a
test and this is one of them. The third
step that is something that most people
skip in testdriven development which is
once your test is green you are expected
to and you must come back to the code
and you have to refactor it because the
reason you are allowed to write bad code
or not care about best practices in
second step so that you can come back to
it in step three you cannot skip this
part. Okay. Now let's see what actually
testdriven development looks like. We
have a requirement which is a task
cannot go straight from to-do to done.
It has to go through doing first or in
progress first. Otherwise there is no
point in keeping this whole status of
doing. And we have no code to enforce
this yet. Okay. So let's first start
with the test. Take a task that is
sitting or that is in to-do. We move it
to done and then we expect an error. We
run it and it fails. Why does it fail?
Because it was expecting an error but
instead it got nil. Why? Because the
move was successful. We have not really
added that condition yet. That is our
phase one which is red. Now let's do the
second phase which is the smallest
amount of change that makes the test
pass. For that we add one if statement
inside the move and then we run it
again. This time it is green. Okay, step
one and step two is done. Now comes step
three because the if statement that is a
business rule and it is sitting in the
middle of a method that also locks a
mutx. It increases a sequence number and
it also trims a history buffer. So what
we do? We take it out into a function
called can move. And that function takes
a column that it is currently in and the
column it is going to. Nothing else.
That's it. And then we run the whole
package again and it is still green. We
changed the code. We changed we improved
the code by refactoring it after step
two. And the test is still passing. That
is what completes the whole test-driven
development loop. There is a lot of
discourse. There's a lot of argument in
the ecosystem regarding test-driven
development. In 2023, the author of
testdriven development, Kent Beck, he
wrote this short article about what the
loop actually means because of all these
arguments. One more resource which
changes how you think about um
test-driven development is this talk by
Ian Cooper which is called TDD. Where
did it all go wrong? And his argument
here is that people took the word unit
which you already mentioned unit test to
mean a class and because of that they
wrote one test class per production
class and they mocked every other thing
every other external integration and
because of that every single refactor
used to break hundreds of tests and that
caused a lot of people to give up on
testdriven development. So his claim
here was that the unit that is not about
the class. The unit is the behavior
because the thing that you test against
is the public interface of a module. And
if you do that you can if you want
rearrange the whole class, rearrange the
whole module without changing the
interface and the tests will remain the
same. They will still pass. And if you
remember the first part of this video
where uh we mentioned that always try to
test the state of the system instead of
the behavior of the system. And this is
what he means because testing the class
it means you are trying to test the
behavior of the module the
implementation of the module instead of
the state that it produced. In 2014,
DHH, the author of the Ruby on Rails
framework, who is also very famous these
days for the Linux framework, he wrote
this very controversial or very famous
article called TDD is dead, long live
testing. And his argument here was that
he is against this test first culture
and against this whole idea of designing
your systems with mockability in mind
and you should directly go for actual
testing and all these things which led
to a lot of discussions between him Kent
Beck who wrote testdriven development
and Martin Fowler who's very famous for
system designs and all stuff. So if you
are curious about the whole ecosystem
surrounding test-driven development then
you can read up on those pieces. What do
we do here? What is our opinion on
testdriven development? Now, in my
opinion, from the way I work, testdriven
development is a very good tool when you
know what the answer is, what it should
look like, but you have not yet figured
out how it should work or how to build
it. For example, uh let's say you are
working on a parser where it is very
easy to figure out what view we want in
return. Let's say you are building a
JSON parser. You pass it a string and
you expect a JSON object, right? Very
easy to figure out the inputs and
outputs. So in that scenario, you can go
with test-driven development because the
figuring out your expectation is the
easiest part compared to the actual
implementation. Similarly,
um a pricing rule in your business logic
or a state machine, all these things
here, test-driven development really
works and it keeps you focused on what
you actually want out of your logic. But
in some scenarios, it is a wrong tool
when you do not know what the answer is
going to look like yet. You are still
figuring out, you are still exploring
the ecosystem, the whole space and you
are trying multiple approaches to reach
a best approach and you are going to
depend on what is it that feels right
before you decide what to stick with. In
those scenarios, which in my opinion is
the case in a lot of situations when you
are building features for your back end
because you have to think about a lot of
trade-offs, a lot of approaches, a lot
of system design. So testdriven
development does not really work in a
lot of situations. It has its own uses
but not a lot. Let's talk about one more
concept called as flaky tests. What is a
flaky test that I've already mentioned?
Flaky test is a test that passes and
fails on the same code which is very
unreliable or unexpected without you
changing anything any code but every
time you run it you get a very different
answer and a flaky test is more harmful
for you as compared to you not having
the test in the first place. Why?
Because if a test is missing, if you do
not have a test for it, you know that
there is a hole. There is something
missing here. But if you have a flaky
test, that changes how you and your team
works because let's say um you deploy
your code and it fails. The test fails
in your CI continuous integration. So
one of your teammates or you say that
okay that test is a little flaky just
run it again. It should pass. Then as
expected it passes and everyone moves on
which builds this behavior and because
of that when someday an actual test
fails which is not flaky but an actual
failure in your system and the first
thing someone does is they just run it
again instead of instantly going for the
fix. So where exactly does this
flakiness property come from? There is a
study from 2014 by this person called
Luo and his colleagues. What they did
was they took 201 real fixes for flaky
tests from different open-source
projects and they try to sort them by
cause and on the top there are three
causes. Async await. Async await is a
test that starts something and then it
waits for it the wrong way. Then
concurrency which means two things
inside the test who are trying to race
each other. And then there is test order
dependency where a test only passes
because another test somewhere it ran
first and that left a state behind.
Those three reasons are the causes for
majority of flaky [snorts] tests. And
interestingly we have already dealt with
the first two. The async aait is the
sleep problem that we saw. And what was
the fix for that which was instead of
trying to fake a sleep you wait for a
signal you wait for a condition not the
time itself. Then for concurrency we
have u things like sync test. if you are
using Go and other libraries and
frameworks have their own primitives for
synchronous testing. But the third one
is new. So let's discuss that. What is
test order dependency? It means that
test B only passes when it runs after
test A. But if it is tried to run alone,
stand alone, then it will fail. Why?
usually because uh test A created some
kind of database row or it set some kind
of global value or it created a file
that test B depends on all of these
scenarios it can be anything. Why is it
bad? Because if your test suite depends
on a particular order every time your
test suite runs in the same order it
always passes. But the moment someone
adds a new test in the middle or they
turn on parallelism to make the test
faster then it starts failing. What can
you do about it? You have three options.
First, you can delete it which is fine
because the test was not really helping
in a lot of ways and it was creating
more issues for the future. And deleting
tests is a practice that pays more often
than you might realize. Or second option
is you can quarantine it which means
that moving it out of the blocking suite
into a separate one which still runs in
the same way but this time you add um
the owner's name the developer's name on
it and a date with a reason of why this
is the way so that uh you can catch it.
You can document that this has to be a
flaky test for this reason. Okay? Or you
can add a retry which is not a good
practice in tests. So in my opinion the
best solution is to quarantine it with a
name and a date and a reason so that the
next time some issue happens the test
starts failing we know that who wrote
that why they wrote it and we can just
communicate with them to find the right
solution. Okay, now that we have a test
suite, how do we measure it? What are
the metrics that we look for to find
whether the test suite is good enough or
not? The first number pretty much all of
us reach out for is code coverage. What
does it mean? Code coverage is basically
the percentage of your code that was
executed while your tests were running.
So when you ask for the code coverage
from your testing tool, the compiler or
the tool it rewrites your code before
building. So what it does is it breaks
each function into basic blocks with no
branches in them and it inserts a
counter at the top of each block. Then
it runs your tests and in the end it
reads the counters. So if a block has
zero count it means that that function
never ran. The problem with coverage as
a only metric is it only records whether
the function ran or not. It does not
record anything about uh whether the
function actually did some work or it
actually checked something. So a test
that calls every single function in your
program in your application and it does
not really assert anything. It does not
really check anything that will anyway
give you 100% coverage. And the second
thing to know is coverage is not just
one number. The most common ones are
line coverage which checks whether a
particular line ran or not. There is
branch coverage which checks whether
each direction of each decision or each
condition was taken or not. And
depending on on what you are checking,
they give different answers for the same
code. If you take a function with one if
statement and no else. If a test goes
through with the condition true, it will
be able to execute every single line of
that function. So the line coverage will
say 100%. But if the condition is false
then that direction will never be taken.
So the branch coverage will tell you 50.
So what does the coverage percentage
actually mean about the quality of your
tests? And the number everyone agrees on
is 80%. In 2014,
two people called Laura and Reed Holmes,
they published a study at the
International Conference on Software
Engineering. What they did was they took
large real world Java programs and they
generated thousands of test suites of
different different sizes. Then they
measured each suit's coverage and they
checked how many actual faults each one
actually caught. And they use this
phrase called controlling for sweet
size. If you just try to correlate
coverage against the number of bugs
found then you will get a very strong
relationship. But that is mostly because
the bigger test suites they cover more
of the code and they will be able to
find more. So what they did was they
held the size as fixed and then they
checked whether the higher coverage
suite of two suites of the same size
found more bugs or not. And the
conclusion here was there is a low to
moderate correlation between coverage
and effectiveness once the size is
controlled and the strength of it. It
depends between various systems. So if
you are using a fixed coverage value as
a quality target for your test suite
then that is not going to give you an
effective test suite. So what should we
do? Should we not respect coverage at
all? Three things that we can take from
that article. First is the numbers that
they published. 60% acceptable, 75
commendable and 90 exemplary. And as per
the article, there is no ideal number
that applies to every single product.
Second thing is what is not covered by
your test is more meaningful than what
is covered. Which means that the report
that you will get from your coverage,
the true value of that report is in the
red lines, not the percentage there. And
the third one was the warning that the
article gave us which is if you make
coverage having 100% coverage as
mandatory what most engineers people
will do is they will write very low
value tests just to hit the coverage
number and they will stop improving
since they have already reached the
coverage number. The article also gives
us a direction to something more useful
which is mutation testing. What is
mutation testing? Mutation testing is a
way of testing your tests. So what it
does is the tool the mutation testing
tool it tries to damage your code on
purpose and it checks whether the tests
that you have written they notice the
damage or not and the share of your
damage your tests your test suite is
able to catch that is the score. So the
tool takes your source code, your
application code and it makes a couple
of small changes everywhere on purpose.
For example, uh if in a condition you
have written greater than
they will make that into greater than or
equal or they will change a plus sign to
a minus sign or they will replace a
return value with zero. Each of those
damaged versions is what we call as a
mutant. then it will run your test suite
against each one of those mutants. If a
test fails, then the mutant is killed
and which is good because your tests
were able to notice the damage. But if
the test still passes, then that mutant
is survived. that mutant is kept which
means that you have a testing code that
is not really doing the checking that it
is expected to do and in the end the
score that you will get is the
percentage of the mutants your tests
were able to kill. So this is a module
it takes a list and returns one page for
it and this is the test someone wrote
for it. If you read the assertions, they
are like it returns something. It
returns an array. It should not throw
the length should be greater than zero.
And now if you look at the coverage here
which is a 100% of the lines because
every line of that function runs during
the tests. So if we go by just coverage
then this job is finished. We are done
with our testing. Now if we run this
program which is called striker for
mutation testing on the same code what
it does it makes 19 small changes to the
source one at a time and it runs the
whole test suite against each one of
those mutants and what we get as a score
is 52
63%.
which means that nine out of those 19
they were able to survive our tests did
not catch those damages. So if you look
at the second survivor the second mutant
that was able to survive the in the loop
it was I less than or equal to offset
plus limit. What striker did it changed
it to I less than offset plus limit. So
now it changes how many items the
function returns but even after that
every test still was able to pass. So
that is the whole value of mutation
testing to test our tests. Let's move on
from uh measuring our test to measuring
our code to code quality. The first
metric that we look at here is called
cyclometric complexity.
And that is a very complex sounding word
which just means that cyclometric
complexity which means that it is a
count of the number of independent parts
through a piece of code. And this
technique comes from a paper written by
someone called Thomas in 1976.
And interestingly this is a technique uh
to get the count you can actually do the
computing by hand. What you do is you
draw the function as a graph and every
straight run of statements is a node and
every jump between them is an edge. So
the formula is edges minus nodes plus
two. And there is a shortcut to that
which is the answer is always 1 plus the
number of decisions points. one for the
function itself plus one for every if
condition, every loop, every case and
every and or or in a condition. So if a
function has no branches in it, then the
count is one. If it has a if condition
then the count is two. Now the opinion
of most people here is the complexity
number for most functions should be 10
and this is what the author himself
wrote in the original paper about uh
that number. As per him this is
reasonable but not magical and he found
this one case where the limit seemed
unreasonable which is a function that is
a big switch statement over many
independent cases. So if you have a 20
case switch statement then the
complexity will become 21 right as per
the formula which is still very easy to
read but it fails the general advice
which is the count should be under 10.
Now our second metric because the first
metric and the general advice about that
metric which is it should be under 10
that clearly failed under our uh switch
statement which was very easy to read
which was very good code but it still
failed the formula. That's why we have a
second metric which is cognitive
complexity. Now this metric is not very
mechanical. It is not a counter. It is
there to measure how hard the code is to
understand as compared to how many paths
it is taking. And this technique was
invented by sonar source. So if we look
from the perspective of this technique
cognitive complexity, it does not really
add anything for the switch statement
itself because if you look at a flat
switch statement, it is very easy to
read. It does not have any cognitive
load. But every time you add any kind of
nesting in there then it grows because
if you see an if statement inside a loop
which is again inside an if statement
that becomes very hard to read and that
whole situation that whole path becomes
very hard to hold in your head as
compared to three different if
statements in a row. So if you look at
both the techniques, a long flat switch
statement, it scores very high on
cyclomatic complexity but it scores very
low on cognitive complexity. Similarly,
if we look at nesting, three levels of
nesting, it scores a moderate level on
cyclometric complexity, but it scores
very high on cognitive complexity. So
here we have a package and we have two
tools. If we go by cyclometric
complexity, the one that counts parts,
the hubs run method, it scores eight and
it comes in the third position behind
the two stream handlers. But if you go
by cognitive complexity, which increases
as you uh increase the amount of
nesting, the same method will score 19.
And now it moves to the top of the list.
same as the websocket handler. But
instead of only going by the numbers
that these tools are giving us, if you
look at the code itself, there are eight
ways you can enter that function. And
that itself is very hard to read because
how deeply it is nested. All in all,
what we get from this discussion about
the code complexity using these two
different tools is do not trust either
tool blindly. Do not take the number as
a hard rule. Instead, look at what
exactly those numbers are pointing you
towards and then as a team take a
decision on what is the right thing to
do. So take those tools as a flagging
tool instead of the base of your
decision. Okay. Now that we have talked
about tests, we have talked about code
complexity. Let's look at a few tools
that that allow us to find problems for
us without even running anything. And
these tools are probably uh the ones you
have already heard a lot of. First one
is a llinter. What is a llinter? A
llinter is a tool that goes through your
source code, your application code, and
every time it finds a particular pattern
that it thinks is a wrong pattern, then
it will complain you. It will show you
some kind of error. And to be clear
here, it does not really check syntax.
That is the job of the compiler, of your
language runtime. And it also does not
check the correctness of your logic, the
correctness of your program, which there
is no universal or reliable way to know
without an actual output, an actual
expectation. It only checks for
patterns. For example, if you have a
comparison, you are doing some kind of
if condition, but the condition that
you're checking, the variable that is
inside the condition that is always
true, which is assigned somewhere
upstream, then it will show you the
error. The l will show you an error that
this condition is always true. Or if uh
you got an error from some kind of
function call, but you did not check
that error, then it will warn you that
um you should check that error properly.
Right? That's what a llinter means. It
checks for patterns. Then we have a
formatter which is the most universally
known tool. It takes your source code
and it writes it in a uh standard layout
typically which is decided by your whole
team and that's it. It does not really
change your program in any way. The
whole job is just to make it more
readable, make it less complex looking.
Then we have type checkers. If you are
using languages like Go, TypeScript, uh
Rust, they all have their own type
checkers typically integrated into your
editor something like VS Code which warn
you when you are using the types wrong.
If you are using a variable and you are
doing some kind of arithmetic operations
on that but that variable somewhere
upstream is declared as string then it
will show you the error that you are
trying to do arithmetic operations on
top of a string but that is the job of a
type checker. There is one more thing
which is called static analysis which is
like a more advanced version of a
llinter. So static analysis means
checking code without running it. And
the way they work is they start at one
point and they try to follow the same
value through your program and check for
a few conditions. That is pretty much
everything uh you can cover on a basic
level about testing and code quality.
Code quality is a very subjective uh
matter. That is why I could not find any
objective metrics, objective tools for
that. So if you are in any ecosystem
like if you are in a typescript
ecosystem [clears throat] then eslint
rules which is a llinter they help you
to some extent to improve your code
quality. Similarly, if you are using Go,
then it also has its own lint. But other
than that there is no particular tool or
deterministic way to decide whether a
code is of high quality or